I have a video for you today that might
make you cringe it's actually pretty
hard to watch because it's a video of
embarrassing erroneous and egregiously
egomaniacal Republican senator Ted Cruz
who went on NBC News over the weekend
and the studio audience laughed in his
face when he tried pushing a totally
debunked conspiracy theory this is
probably one of you've heard me mention
Republicans have been pushing the
conspiracy theory that Ukraine actually
meddled in the 2016 election and the
point of this is to indirectly sort of
try to justify Donald Trump trying to
extort Ukraine to smear Joe Biden in
exchange for releasing military aid and
having a meeting between presidents
Olinsky and Donald Trump at the White
House this is now subject the subject of
the impeachment articles that Democrats
announced today so it's a conspiracy for
which there is no evidence but the true
trump brownnosers continue to push it
check out what Ted Cruz had to say
notice that the crowd starts laughing at
him and this this is how it went
do you believe Ukraine meddled in the
American election in 2016 I do and I
think there's considerable evidence you
do you do and Chuck let me say this is a
senator this sort of strikes me as odd
because you went through a primary
campaign with this president he launched
a birtherism campaign against you
he went after your faith he threatened
to quote spill the beans about your wife
about something he pushed the National
Enquirer story which we now know he had
a real relationship with they say you're
driving that red line up although but
it's very good day tonight is it let me
ask you this is it not possible that
this president is capable of creating a
false narrative about somebody in order
to help him politically except that's
not what happened the president released
the transcript of the phone call you can
read what was said on the phone calls
not in the Bible
now of course this is one of the big
lies that they tell over and over and
over again and it's sort of starts to
become the truth they did not release
the transcript Ted Cruz refers to the
transcript they're talking about the
July 20
five phone call between Donald Trump and
president zalenski that was a more than
30 minute phone call they released a few
pages of the transcript it is not a
transcript it's an excerpt but they
continue to call it the transcript but
that's not really what we're looking at
today what we're looking at today is how
Ted Cruz is still willing to repeat the
Ukraine meddling conspiracy absent any
evidence and fortunately the crowd
laughed at him I actually like that
Chuck Todd who I'm not a particularly
big fan of at all Chuck Todd actually
brings up to Ted Cruz why are you doing
this
Ted why are you doing the president's
dirty work particularly after he
attacked your wife's physical appearance
he implicated you in bizarre
conspiracies he went after you endlessly
he nicknamed you lyin Ted and it's stuck
he seems to have pushed the tabloid that
he's connected to to print a completely
bogus story about you why is Ted Cruz
doing this maybe there is something to
be said for studio audiences trying to
apply shame to Republicans who say
ridiculous things maybe shame is the
only workable strategy we have left we
know that as far as Donald Trump is
concerned he seems to be unable to feel
shame but maybe some of these other
Trump brown nosers are able to feel
shame and maybe it gets them to rethink
the things that they're publicly saying
I'm thinking out loud here it may do
nothing at all now as a side note as I
mentioned Donald Trump went after the
appearance the attractiveness of Ted
Cruz's wife if you are Ted Cruz's wife
and you know that that happened during
the Republican primary and it's not just
an attack on Ted Cruz it's it's Trump
going after Ted Cruz's wife's physical
appearance and then Ted Cruz is out
there peddling the same type of stuff to
placate Donald Trump day after day after
day it's gonna be a little weird for Ted
Cruz's relationship behind the scenes no
does anybody agree with that let me know
what you think but the bigger picture
here is that you know we talked at the
top of the show now that Democrats have
filed articles of impeachment what are
going to be the Republican strategies in
order to try to defend Donald Trump's
actions number one of course of course
is going to be that the entire desire to
impeach Donald
Trump is not based in fact it was
decided back in 2017 brother Ladera it's
a witch hunt it's a hoax that's all it
is that's gonna be one argument then
they will get to arguing that none of
the witnesses whose testimony led to
articles of impeachment were fact
witnesses they will talk about it was
all hearsay that's another layer which
they are going to use to try to sow
disinformation around impeachment and
then number three likely is going to be
again Ukraine was super corrupt from was
right and what he did Ukraine meddled in
the 2016 election Trump was concerned
about it despite the fact that we've
heard testimony from numerous witnesses
now that Donald Trump never expressed
concern about corruption in Ukraine
prior to this request for a favor that
took place so Ted Cruz deserves to be
laughed at for this glad that the
audience did but this Ukraine meddled in
2016 thing is not going to go away and I
wouldn't be surprised to see it play a
larger and larger role in the context of
the upcoming what may be an impeachment
trial in the Senate that we seem to be
heading in the direction of